- [Gary] I want to
be in the room in those
early bottled water meetings.
Like people were like
get the fuck out of here.
It's free, it's free.
It's in our kitchen for free.
("Unstoppable" by This Is Wolff)
Morning DailyVee.
8 A.M. in my office,
Ty guy.
- Yo.
- [Gary] I got you some coffee.
About to do a
meeting with Inscape,
an incredible meditation studio
and app that I invested in.
Nice and quiet in the office.
Which is actually not
nice 'cause I hate silence.
It freaks me the fuck out.
Oh, you're wearing
that dude's sweatshirt.
Tyler's easily bribed.
Have a good day.
Oh, I did have this stuff.
This was great.
- [Tyler] Did you?
- Yeah.
You guys put it in there, right?
- Yo Lotus, why you trying to
make me super fat you dick face?
This is delicious.
Yummy. It's good.
Get it out of here
before I eat all of it.
- [Man] 'Sup, brother?
- Good to see ya.
- [Man] How've you been?
- [Gary] How you been?
Podcasts are winning.
It's underpriced.
That's it. It's
just very simple.
It's very simple.
So I hear you on the library,
I'm just putting that
on the side for a second.
I'm trying to be
practical of what would I do if
I was running this business.
I think you should
really debate the podcast.
I think you would crush.
It would matter.
And I think the guests
would matter. You know?
I just don't
know what else to say.
It was amazing when you guys
said New York Times like what
went through my
body which is my God,
literally what went
through my body is like,
okay,
the amount of impact Rich
the Kid sitting in your studio
and putting it on his
Instagram meaning
versus the entire
New York Times article.
They're not even in
the same stratosphere.
It's just quite scary.
- [Man 2] It's true.
- Do you know how much
Kylie Jenner is getting paid
right now for a post on
Instagram and Snapchat?
Do you know what
the latest price is?
- [Man 3] Million dollars.
- $1.3 million
for a singular post.
("Stay Awake" by
NUFSEDSAYNOMORE)
Look, it comes down
to content distribution,
content distribution.
- [Woman] Yes.
- And buying
underpriced attention.
- [Woman] Yes.
- Underpriced
attention is Facebook.
Underpriced attention
is Instagram influencers.
Underpriced
attention is podcasting,
Alexa skills.
Everything works.
That billboard works
out there, it's overpriced.
It shouldn't be $7,000 a month.
- [Man 4] Yeah.
- That's all.
We really, really can't wait
until we start selling oxygen
'cause it's a
foregone conclusion.
(group laughter)
If you just look at the trend.
I want to be in the room in
those early
bottled water meetings.
Like people were like
get the fuck out of here.
It's free, it's free.
It's in our kitchen for free.
Guys, it's a foregone conclusion
and it's a big market.
How are you guys?
- [Man 5] How are you, Gary?
- How are you?
We are living through
such a big shift of the
maturity of the internet itself.
All of us have lived
through this internet thing.
It's just very young.
If you could leave with anything
on a macro is how early this
really is and how it impacts
supermarkets or varsity jackets
or real estate or lending.
It's going to continue to
compound and the one thing
I want to make sure everybody
realizes is that Uber and Amazon
and Airbnb are the previews,
they're not the anomalies.
Every single person
here is gonna be effected by
it in a meaningful way.
More so than
they're effected by it now.
And I think the key is you need
to extract value out of it and
don't allow it to
extract value out of you.
I'll tell you this, it's a
long-winded answer to this.
It's binary.
You can't be half-pregnant.
If you get into
the self help stuff,
people like to do things
like me with this part cut out.
I just eat shit 24/7/365,
people don't want to.
Alright, cool.
I'll be back.
Alright, I'll figure it out.
You got it. Let's go.
("Never Give Up" by Betagreen)
I'm just taking a piss.
Give me a second.
(laughs)
The problem is
the content has to
be contextual to the platform.
The reason I don't like things
that take a piece of content and
distribute 'em is because the
creative is not contextual to
where it's being deployed.
People are using social media
as distribution instead of as a
native place to story tell.
When you put a piece of content
to somebody in Germany of why
Bahrain, first of all you have
to understand the psychology of
a German user on
Twitter before you even get to
what you're gonna put on there.
If you just use Hootsuite
because it lets you post on all
these platforms in one shot,
you've lost the purpose of what
we're trying to accomplish.
You've achieved
putting a piece of content
on 47 websites officially.
Who gives a fuck if you
didn't sell any packages?
Cool, I love you guys.
Let's take a quick photo.
Super fast.
("Never Give Up" by
Betagreen)
Alright guys, heading out.
Got a couple of drink meetings.
Bunch of cancellations.
It's been a weird day.
Had a weird cancellation
run back and forth.
Anyway, life is good.
Bunch of new clients
that you couldn't show.
Maybe you can write in
"Client Time, Client Time,
New Business Pitch".
Big one, huge fucking company.
I think we got a shot.
I'm excited.
Running VaynerMedia.
It's what I do.
What else?
Anything else interesting?
Facebook continues to dominate.
- [Other Tyler] Actually
a lot about podcasts.
- Yeah, I like podcasts. Really?
Good, so let's do that for you.
I believe in trading attention
and I think podcasting is
grossly underpriced and
I think all of you should start
a podcast in the same way that
all of you are starting vlogs.
Go do it, figure it out.
It's even easier.
It's your voice.
You don't have to be handsome.
See ya.
("Never Give Up" by Betagreen)